I wanted
to share
some new
video for for you
all and everyone
watching of what
appears to be a Russian combat
training instructor
for the 247th Regiment and Strav
pleading to a regional governor
pleading for more equipment and
Let me play it
right We've got your fighters
that you sent to us here in Stav
Krai are almost completely naked
They have no medical kits
and they have just one tournique
Any one of you come over here?
As you can see,
they have almost no protection
and just two plates.
They don't have any thermal unde
The boys are freezing
Now, General,
we can't authenticate this video
but I just will be clear.
It is in line
with previous
reports, videos, phone
calls, of Russian troops
complaining about unbelievably i
and unacceptable supply situatio
for a modern military.
So is this part of what
we're seeing right now?
Is there any way for Russian for
to succeed on the ground
with the conditions that
we just heard outlined there?
Short answer, Aaron.
No, absolutely not.
Here's here's what you have to c
Those new trainer trainees
that are coming in
after being mobilized
are prepared to be trained.
They're also prepared to be equi
That's individual training.
They teach them things
like rifle marksmanship
and first aid
and how to move in
small units and things like that
But that's just the first step.
And that takes weeks after that.
It takes months
to have them learn
what's called
combined arms operations, tanks,
working with infantry,
working with armor,
working with engineers,
literally takes months of traini
There was a Natal report submitt
that said the earliest,
if everything goes right,
that Russia can get mobilized,
troops on the front lines is May
That's months away and that's co
Considering that they had everyt
they need.
The fact that those soldiers don
even have tourniquets, Band-Aids
you showed a neurosurgeon in Ukr
operating on a brain the other n
in a combat support hospital.
These guys don't even have tourn
to wear on their uniforms.
So that means
they probably don't have medics.
They don't have first aid statio
They don't have support hospital
All of those.
All of those things contribute
to making a modern army.
And Russia continues to fail mis